hallo mein name ist luca und vor einiger
zeit habe ich bereits eine logo real
versus fake video hochgeladen linke
safe die würden ja nicht rot blau blau
machen
hamse anscheinend doch gemacht auch
heute meine damen und herren werden wir
kein will versus technologie fürs machen
sondern can you get the logo wir
bekommen also logos eingeblendet in
denen etwas fehlt und wir sollen sagen
zu welchem unternehmen das gehört und
damit fangen jetzt an bis dn das heißt
meine damen und herren für jedes logo
bekommen wir einen punkt das hier ist
das erste logo das ja mal richtig schwer
ihr könnt ihr aber auch einfach wieder
mit raten und zwar einfach in die
kommentare schreiben 1 erstes logo das
würde ich denken was das ist uns weiter
und so fort natürlich irgendwelche
experten wenn sich wie das komplette
video anschauen und dann alles richtig
haben ihr seid richtig cool hier würde
ich sagen dass das auf jeden fall shell
ist das heißt wir warten jetzt mal ab
und wir sehen schon als untertitel
natürlich schell als nächstes logo haben
wir hier oh mein gott ich kenn das logo
nicht thomas selber nachdenken ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung es ist ein ging
also ich habe keine ahnung was das
barclays stimmt die englische borgen da
hätte ich wirklich drauf kommen können
eigentlich auch wegen der englischen
fußball-liga das hier vorne ist
irgendein wie heißt das dass es
irgendwann mobilfunkunternehmen glaube
ich und zwar ist es weiter
ich darf ich sollte mich manchmal
vergraben geben bisher habe ich einfach
eins von drei richtig
das hier ist relativ easy das soll
glaube ich jeder kennen das ist nämlich
pepsi wir sehen uns auch schon
eingeblendet hier pepsi das heißt ich
habe zwei von vier richtig nächstes logo
das playboy aber ich verstehe trotzdem
nicht warum die sonnen rasen als lohan
also auch hier die einblendung playboy
dann haben wir als nächstes logos
hyundai oder honda
keine ahnung alter ich würde einfach
da ihm das warten nicht ab und wir sehen
es war hyundai es bleibt dabei dass ich
drei von sechs richtig habe das hier
dakota
glaube ich mal schauen
nein es ist um ruhe die man so
sportsachen und so
muttersein luca ich bin echt unglaublich
schlecht hier drin ich habe auch hiervon
wirklich überhaupt keine ahnung es sind
halt doch einfach echt so amerikanische
logos aber halt natürlich auch weltweit
agieren aol
darauf hätte ich wirklich kommen können
das hier ist meine ich walkman oder sony
ericsson ich bin mir nicht sicher freuen
es ist walkman kriege ich dafür jetzt
den punkt ich weiß jetzt schon nicht
mehr wie viele punkte ich habe das hier
ist das nächste logo 11freunde dass es
irgend so ein messenger dienst das ist
irgendwas man hat dann auch noch fünf
sekunden zeit um es irgendwie zu erraten
es ist kompakt was ist denn das
us-amerikanische hersteller von
computern oder so war ja nah dran mit
messenger-dienst nächstes logo haben wir
hier motorola das weiß ich noch mein
ziel ist es mittlerweile einfach mehr
richtig zu haben als nicht richtig zu
haben bei der logitech habe ich ja
nahezu alles gewusst dass hier ist ralph
lauren
das weiß ich und das sehen wir auch
jetzt eingeblendet wohl aber hat polo
ralph lauren das hier sollte glaube ich
aston martin sein bin ich mir sogar
relativ sicher also hier drin müsste
aston martin steht ich weiß jetzt nicht
ob dies zu unterschreiben oder da rein
schreiben ja genau die machen beide ist
dass man aston martin nächstes logo
haben wir hier
wie heißt das noch mal erfreut ich hab
keine ahnung ich würde sagen dass der
tankstelle ja total alter wie so komme
ich etwas ist das ich glaube das ist
marriott also eine hotelkette falls ich
nicht registriert das ist derzeit bei
mir wirklich so ein 50 50 spiel das hier
ages bc ich bin mir da wirklich nicht
sicher ob das ages bc ist ein essay des
bc okay da bin ich mir auf jeden fall
richtig sicher gewesen
hier haben wir unicef das sollten glaube
ich auch die meisten kennen ja sehen wir
uns doch gerade noch mal richtig
eingeblendet hier
dann haben wir hier vorne war
das amerikanische pendant bin ich bin
ganz ganz sicher ich kenne das
unternehmen auch es ist sharon ich kann
das unternehmen doch nicht ich bin mir
überhaupt nicht sicher was das sein
könnte ich sag jetzt einfach mal sony
ericsson möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen
und heulen freunde ich bin echt dumm da
stimmen aber wir machen wir direkt
weiterhin mit dem nächsten logo
playstation also da sind übel schwierige
logos und dann wieder übels leichter ich
glaube allerdings wenn man sich als
amerikaner das video anschaut dann
kriegt man auch alles irgendwie hin weil
man halt mit den logos jeden tag
irgendwie in verbindung steht das ist
glaube ich bentley bentley das ist ein
filme hersteller ich bin mir allerdings
nicht sicher walt disney ist es nicht es
ist teamwork
ich kenne die ganze sache auch das kenne
ich also summa summarum look zeigen
schon fünf sechs mal mit geflogen und
fast war das denn solche sachen echt
nicht hinkriege auch wenn ich die logos
irgendwie kenne also das ist ja wieder
klar dass spotify hier das kennt man ja
auch in europa ist es ja relativ kraft
verbreitet aber so british airways com
was ist
das ist irgendwie irgendein wir glaube
ich
englisches bier aber ich habe das nicht
hingekriegt
[Musik]
ich finds echt krass wie wenig zeit für
diese sachen hat hier weilburg ich kenne
das logo auch so scansafe tripadvisor
also diese plattform wo man anderen
leuten tipps gibt über eine reise gibt
es bei jörg die hose
[Musik]
ich nicht drauf gekommen dass das dies
sage ich ganz ehrlich das ist marlboro
dass ich bin nichtraucher aber das logo
kann also hier sehen wir jetzt auch
marlboro eingeblendet genau als nächstes
logo haben wir hiervon anderer armer an
der armor das unternehmen was sehr groß
geworden ist steve kelly hier an der ama
sehen wir auch wieder eingeblendet dass
meine damen und herren ist paypal das
ist finde ich echt relativ krass und
zwar sind der einerseits unternehmen bei
die ich wirklich ganz genau kenne dann
unternehmen wo ich überhaupt keine
andere
was soll das sein uhren sony pictures
war das meine damen und herren hätte ich
auch locker hingekriegt tesla
es ist wirklich so ein durcheinander
irgendwie manche sachen kriege ich
perfekt hin weil ich die genau kenne
aber andere sachen sind eigentlich
sollte ich glaube ich alles wissen mit
einer gewissen bildung allerdings ist
die ja leider nicht bei mir vorhanden in
der tat
freilich weiß woran es liegt ich weiß
warum ich hier keine logos erraten kann
mir fehlt einfach
ja mal schauen ob ich etwas hinkriegen
nächstes logo hier freunde wir sehen
blackberry leicht blackberry brille
nicht vorher darauf kommen dass ich die
mal aufsetzen muss don't often nächstes
logo was wir hier haben ach das ist doch
ganz klar das ist auch mein gott ich
kenne das irgendwo her
ja
es ist auf jeden fall auch irgend so
eine hilfsorganisation world health
organization ich finde das kann man
erzählen lassen
das hier ist nvidia weiß ich natürlich
ganz genau weil ich diese brille hierauf
habe nvidia sehen wir auch die
eingeblendete freunde von denen es meine
grafikkarte
dann haben wir hier sony ericsson ich
habe schon sehr oft gesagt aber diesmal
ist es wirklich sony ericsson also wir
sehen hier eingeblendet sony ericsson
seitdem ich diese brille aufhabe habe
ich drei von vier richtig hier haben wir
hamburgs paar sekunden später history of
wow
lufthansa
lufthansa das tal 1 wohin ich wusste
irgendwas mit flugzeugen was kannst du
eigentlich also diese brille hat mir
bisher so circa 50 der saarower keine
ahnung alters 2000 jahre später die casa
was ist denn picasa das hier ist
irgendein spiel wahrscheinlich fürs
handy aber ich habe auch überhaupt keine
ahnung dragon irgendwas mortal kombat ok
mortal kombat auch keine ahnung was das
sein soll laut youtube
ich habe glaube ich 20 bis 30 also ich
bin smart an der stelle mich dass häufig
videos allerdings auch werden meine
damen und herren diese brille werde ich
jetzt allerdings mal wieder absetzen
wenn euch das heutige video gefallen hat
das gerne wahr einen like da wollt ihr
dass ich eventuell noch mal so ein logo
chris machte vielleicht noch mal sogar
ein can you get the logo fürs oder
vielleicht auch noch mal ein real wird
es fake logik willst ich habe gerade
gesehen dass es mittlerweile sogar sowie
diverses fake logo chris videos gibt wo
drei oder vier logos zur auswahl stehen
von denen dann eins richtig ist und zwei
oder drei fall ständig auf jeden fall
war interessant zu sehen ob ich das
ganze hinbekommen würde in meinem ersten
video dazu gleich der relativ gut
allerdings wenn ihr wollt dass jetzt
ganz mal wieder mache last 60.000
leichter freunde ist eine große zahl ich
weiß 60.000 leute sind zwei mal 30.000
leute mich auf jeden fall freuen wenn
ihr der bock drauf habe bei mir macht
das unfassbar viel spaß ihr können mit
raten aber jetzt will ich sagen kommt
das outro glas wasser ziehen
hier können jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
schenken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent zeit
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
bekommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]